New developments
swirling around embattled Congressman
George Santos
this morning, now
facing 13 federal charges.
The House will now not vote
on whether to kick him out of Congress.
Instead, Republicans
punted the issue back to the House Ethics
Committee, a move
that basically allows them
to avoid weighing in directly,
at least now on the Capitol steps.
Last night
Santos vowed he is not going anywhere.
And while he spoke, members
from the opposing parties
began to heckle Santos and each other.
An investigation?
Yes, sir.
Did you talk, Speaker
McCarthy, ahead of the vote?
No, I did not. I allowed the plot.
I allowed the process to play itself out
the body has to kick him out.
He's embarrassing.
Oh, he's embarrassing Joe Biden.
For what?
Oh, Biden is embarrassing.
Him.
You got to save the party.
Your party is hanging by.
Got rogue.
We got to get rid of Biden.
The party is up for these heinous crimes.
A well-oiled
machine seen as Melina Zona
live on Capitol Hill.
All right,
so that was quite a scene, Melanie.
But what happens now?
Okay, so what happened yesterday
was House Republicans
essentially bought themselves
a little bit more time
when it comes
to dealing with Jorge Santos.
Democrats had wanted to force
a floor vote on a resolution
that would have expelled him.
But Kevin McCarthy came up
with essentially an off ramp
in order to shield his members
from having to go on the record and take
what would be
a very potentially tough vote
for some of them.
So instead of voting on the resolution
itself, the House voted yesterday
to refer the resolution
to the House Ethics Committee.
They voted along party lines to do that.
So it now
heads to the House Ethics Committee.
Essentially, this is a delay tactic.
But look, the House Ethics Committee
has already been investigating
Jorge Santo since March.
This committee,
it is bipartisan,
made up of equally Republicans
and Democrats,
but it is not known to move
very quickly and in fact, John,
typically when a member is indicted,
the DOJ will ask the House Ethics
Committee to take a step back
to not interfere with their work.
However, in this case,
sources told me and my colleagues, Manu
Raju and Lauren Fox
that the House Ethics
Committee is planning to move ahead,
but that doesn't mean necessarily
that they are going to move quickly.
So it could be weeks,
if not months before we make them
see to make a recommendation
on whether or not to expel Jorge Campos.
And even then,
the full house
would still have to vote on expulsion,
which requires a two thirds majority.
So all that to say,
it could be a while
before we see any punitive action
against Jorge Santos.
But in the meantime,
Democrats are making clear
that they are not
going to let Republicans
live that vote down.
And they are going to remind voters
that Jorge Santos is still,
as of right now, a current member
of the Republican Party.
And Republicans
What happened, as you
so aptly point out,
they bought themselves
some time
where they don't have to say
whether they think Jorge Santos
should be in or out of Congress.
Melania's vote to keep us posted
Thanks so much for joining the table,
Sara Matthews, former
deputy press secretary
for the Trump
administration, and Ashley Allison,
former national coalitions
director for the Biden-harris
2020 Campaign
Ladies, thank you for joining us.
We've got Sara here
as well as Julia still with us.
I want to start with with you, Sarah.
Sara Matthews.
A lot of Sarah's you
you heard one of the congressmen saying
have some dignity.
New Yorkers need better.
And this was obviously somebody
from New York yelling at Santos.
Is he right?
He's 100% correct.
I do wish that Jorge Santos
had the dignity to resign.
Obviously,
we see that isn't going to happen.
He's already
announced his intent
to run for reelection.
But I will say
I do think it might be a little premature
to expel him
solely based on that indictment alone.
I think with, you know, in the past,
I don't recall any other member
or senator
being expelled
just based on an indictment
so we do need to let the Ethics
Committee process play out.
There
probably has not been another person,
though, in his position
that has lied so much
and it has been proven.
So I'm curious Ashleigh,
what you make of that
and whether you think like, hey,
let's put politics aside,
which no one ever can, but,
you know, let's do this.
Let's look at what he has done
and say
this is a bad representation of us.
It really is.
I mean, as Americans,
just in general, having someone like that
serving in Congress,
I also feel really bad
for his constituents.
He says, oh,
they elected me to represent them.
No, they elected a character
you developed.
They did not elect the real Jorge Santos.
Because they didn't know who he was
because he did not tell the truth.
And the reality is, is
he isn't going to be expelled right now
because the Republicans
have such a slim majority in the House.
Their numbers are not in their favor
when they're trying to pass legislation.
And so it doesn't work for them.
And so that's
where the political nature
comes back into it.
It is not about
whether he did something wrong.
Everyone knows he's done something wrong,
but they need the votes as Republicans.
Right. Service.
Can I ask you a quick question on this?
Does it surprise you
where we are right now?
Because I feel like
20 years ago
we may not be in this position.
You know, it's interesting you say that.
I think the in the past few years,
especially in the digital era,
it's allowed people to create online
personalities of flat people
to be anonymous.
It's allowed people
to shape their history
and shape their record in some senses.
In another,
we have more accountability than ever
because you can just Google the truth.
And what's crazy about the Jorge
Santos story
is, by the way,
thank God for local news,
because there's a local Long Island paper
that broke the story.
But what's crazy about it
is that he was able
to develop this crazy persona,
but also he was able
to get away with it for so long.
And so am I surprised that we're here?
In a sense, yes.
Because we should have been more holding
our local politicians
to much more higher standards.
We should have been investigating them.
We should have known this earlier.
But in a way, no,
because in the digital era, it's
not shocking to see people
become caricatures of themselves online.
And that's where we ended up
where we are.
And we should state
that the Republicans in his district
have called for him to step down.
That has not obviously happened.
And that's politics.
It's also a precedent as well.
I think there's been two congressmen
expelled since the Civil War
I believe so.
And they were both convicted.
I was going to say an indictment.
It's not a conviction. Exactly.
So I guess the Republicans
don't do that for.
And they have to clear otherwise.